torture the term is thrown around so
flippantly nowadays it's lost all
meaning liberals will tell you oh my
gosh we are torturing people in
Guantanamo Bay and America is no better
than any other country President Obama
has shown his intent to close Gitmo
because of this let's take a look at
some of these torture techniques used at
Club Gitmo okay one of them is
repeatedly playing children's songs tell
us where the bomb is okay yeah we've got
slight sleep deprivation hey wake up
wake up again wake up and then the usual
restraints isolation yelling now it
should be noted that every detainee must
get 3 square meals an adequate hydration
diet yeah because this doesn't taste
like diets dying death to America
people out there do you honestly believe
that America is losing its moral
high-ground and consider this torture
say what you want I know what would
happen to me if I were captured by our
enemies yeah that makes sense
Muslim terrorists have no compassion I'm
guessing you can't just flush a Bible
call it a day no people love to throw
out waterboarding granted it's no walk
in the park you're not gonna see your
friends anytime soon hey sweetie
let's go waterboarding this weekend for
those of you who don't know enough about
waterboarding ask a Navy SEAL as many of
them have been waterboarded as a part of
their training wait is the United States
military torture its own troops case in
point the very fact that Abu Ghraib was
considered such a travesty and so
appalling to Americans proves that we
hold a higher standard than our enemies
I was as upset as most people but if I'm
captured by Muslim terrorists and the
worst they do is strip me down naked and
laugh at me I would be thanking God that
I got off so easy ah
yeah mega noon oh okay
dammit you know the people who've got to
be really upset about this or the
terrorists they're suffering and torture
is supposed to bring glory to Allah the
closest thing they'll ever get to their
William Wallace disembowelment freedom
moment is a possible pink belly
Disko medica
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]